well we're here in Liverpool and I'm
joined by John Burton he's a former gang
boss and now he spends his time helping
prisoners find work John thanks so much
for being on the show that's great nice
to meet you and thanks for having me now
obviously I want to talk to you about
um your life of crime what you do now
and also some of the issues about crime
in Liverpool at the moment you
understand that well better than most
but what I want to do is you have such a
fascinating
quite astonishing story what was it like
being a young boy in Liverpool in the
80s I loved it it was great
um I used to I was born in Brazen in
Liverpool Town Center off Foxhall Road
moved on to an estate probably seven
eight hundred hours and these were all
people who come from tenements
Apartments flat stuff like that and all
moved on to this estate so it was
basically fines and loads of new mates
and loads of new families that moved on
and that's what we read he was probably
God he was probably well to understand
the same age all along around together
at the same time how on Earth did you go
from this kid
having a lot of fun loving life as you
said how did you go from that to at the
age of 11 selling drugs on the streets
what was going on I think when I was
about 11 I think a group of me and a
group of me mate started smoking weed
and then from there we started buying
bits of weeds and selling it to just get
our own smoke and stuff like that and
then as you're growing up a little bit
people take notice and then I ended up
sort of working with older ladstone when
I was about 13 14 and obviously I was do
people say I got groomed and exploited
actually I didn't I wanted to do it you
were named
as The Mastermind of a one million
conspiracy to sell one million pound
conspiracy spelled drugs across the city
yeah and it was then 211.
I got caught in 2000.
are you like literally like are you have
you become the gang Master at this point
not the gang masterboard because I was
probably top of the tree and top of the
tree means it was me that was sauce and
the cigarette or the drugs it was me
that was putting it all together and it
was me that was sort of working with my
friends so you're running people now
yeah yeah
there are so many horror stories of
gangs uh depicted in TV shows on Films
documentaries like the one you featured
in which was Liverpool narcos
is it really like that was it a life of
violence as well
when you're in a when you're in a drug
World it can be yeah because what you've
got to understand in the drug world
it's about getting your drugs into the
country it's about shipping them drugs
around to different people and then it
becomes a problem when someone doesn't
pay bills and stuff like that on it were
you violent presumably in them days you
have to be you went into jail before
2012 when you got the big Century 2011
yeah so you so you came so you've been
in you came out and then you've got the
big sentence right so I went away in
early 2000s got out in 2005. carried on
yeah come out and carried on I got
caught in 2011. I got a nine and a half
year sentence and then another five
years on top of that right and then so
you now you now you're facing 14 years
in jail yeah is that the moment you
thought I've got to check no no no I
want to go back in and want them
watching I'll come in and I ended up
going to a category a uni which is a
circum high security unit is that so
you're one of the highest securities
it is but that's where people think but
when you're the prisoner you're going
into just it's normal people like you
have been with some some are saving 20
30 40 years and you're in with murderers
and really violent people right yeah I
suppose you were a really violent person
you come onto that category when when
you're serving drugs and if the police
want to make um
want to make you pay for what you've
done then they'll put you in like a
Qatar unit you basically come out what
changed for you
um I was sent down to the Isle of shepi
in Kent and I'd have to do my last few
years there
seeing what I put my children through my
family through also traveling down there
17 18 hours on a round trip to come and
see me for an hour
I just thought you know what it's time
to sort of get a grip now my family
travels everywhere how long have you
been in prison
where you thought okay I can't do this
three years so you did three years
you're still kind of
being a bit nefarious really yeah I was
bad from the Northwest so I couldn't go
to any prisons in the Northwest so it
was shipped out of the North because you
were literally organizing well they said
they had too much influence on Prison
officers
prisons so you moved here and then you
have this Epiphany thing I can't do this
to my family
so your Epiphany was you couldn't put
your family through it you came out you
couldn't come home so that must have
been really hard but then you set up
this social Enterprise
what does it do so it helps people in
prison people coming out of prison and
it helps them to rehabilitate and what I
I'm like a thunder disrupter I don't
like putting courses on that'll take
four weeks when you just want to draw
down funds and when we can put someone
on a week two week course or a
three-week course depending on what type
of job it is and just let's get them
into work
if we keep people outside for four five
six weeks on Universal Credit not
getting much of an income
the opportunities are going to come in
front of them and then before you know
it click of a finger you're back in
prison and you've been awarded the
Robert Corbett award during a ceremony
in the House of Commons during this
ceremony lady Val Corbett said in this
year alone 182 people on their program
have achieved industry qualifications
with the 98 success rate yeah that must
feel
just like right the wrongs of the past
for you a bit it does it does and like
someone said to me how do you feel about
getting your rewards I went look I
wanted to receive an awards I said but
my Awards is seeing people rehabilitate
and get a life after prison that's my
rewards watching people going into I
just wanted to now talk to you about
Olivia What's Happening Here in
Liverpool on the 22nd of August Olivia
Pratt corball was killed after a gunman
fired shots into her home at about 10
p.m chased by another man this incident
has not just shot Liverpool it's
reverberate around the country and
everyone
parents I mean just everyone like for a
little girl to be killed in that manner
is is beyond imaginable
um
how has it impacted the community here
and how do you feel about it as someone
that was involved in this sort of crime
and gun crime this it's like now I speak
to a lot of people about the Ripple
effects and think before you do
so when you go and do something and you
don't think about doing it then these
are the Ripple effects that happen along
the way and unfortunately there was a
young girl who was killed and it's it's
not on
you know that that poor girl was you
know she was behind a door but that guy
run into their house he had no right to
run into their house and her mom and her
mom got shot through the hands and the
same bullet went and killed Olivia can
you imagine how it's it's awful it is
it's really bad and you know and I know
probably a lot of people in the criminal
worlds are not even happy about it
happening
but it's the Ripple effects of not
thinking about stuff there's a 200 000
reward
being offered for information leading to
the conviction of those responsible it's
the biggest reward in Crime Stoppers
history
how can they not find this person and
how can people in the criminal
organizations in Liverpool not hand this
person over well I don't understand I
don't understand that myself but you
know it's it's who it was or how it was
done no one's really going to know but
the police must have
um evidence and stuff because they're
arresting people for an assistant
offenders and stuff like that so they
must have names that they're sort of
putting it down let me put it to another
way are you surprised that the killer
has still not been found yeah
when he got killed a long time ago he
was names flying rounds everywhere and
they eventually got the killer in the
end
is the person being protected by I 100
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't tell you
that but you know something something's
not right but I'm pretty sure look the
biggest gang in this country are the
police
and I'm pretty sure they will catch the
kill 100 because they're putting
everything into it to find out who it is
how he's done it and what it is and it
won't be it won't be long before the
killers found John thank you thanks for
telling me you're welcome your story
that's the work you do with prisoners I
mean it's
it's a great thing that you do now and
thanks for coming on the show not a
problem we've got to help rehabilitate
people so to become better people in
life that's the way I see you thanks
thank you